[Applaudissements]
alors
tous bon voilà rassurez vous je suis pas
aussi moche en vrai en fait c'est juste
pas photogénique apparemment bon ça fait
bizarre d'être devant autant de monde
déjà merci d'être venus aussi nombreux
et puis ça fait surtout bizarre d'être à
la place de ce professeur zafy vous
savez celui qui a la lourde tâche de
réveiller un amphithéâtre en pleine
digestion est ce que je vais faire du
mieux que je peux alors j'ai 21 ans et
je m'appelle donc maxime doyen et
d'après mes calculs j'ai passé à peu
près 15 % en trente ans de vie assis
dans une salle de classe
et j'ajouterai que j'ai passé 3 voire 4
% pour les plus courageux à faire des
devoirs réviser des examens réception et
c'est donc un cinquième de ma vie
finalement été consacrée à la scolarité
et c'est beaucoup
donc forcément en tant qu'élève moi ça
m'intéresse ce qui est système scolaire
etc
mais en tant qu'adulte enfin que parents
pensent que ça vous intéresse pour les
parents cette nation ça vous intéresse
aussi encore plus parce que vous souciez
de l'éducation corps à votre enfant et
c'est normal quand on sait que l'école
prend tout notre temps quand on y est et
en fait défini notre futur quand on n'y
sommes plus et c'est pour cette raison
que je vais vous démontrer essayer de
démontrer par a plus b que il faut
absolument que nous changions notre
système scolaire au moins pour les
petites classes alors moi
personnellement je suis né car est ce
qu'il ya des cercles dans la salle des
hexagones bon avant vous perdre un petit
peu plus vous expliquer ouais à l'instar
des travaux de michel dib un neurologue
parisien est d'ailleurs de ses confrères
il est avéré que nous naissons avec une
prédétermination de nos domaines de
prédilection voilà alors évidemment il
évolué pendant notre éducation il évolue
en fonction de notre environnement
milieu social et rencontres qu'on va
faire et c'est alors par la suite ne
vous perdez pas à suis à trouver une
logique entre les planches de metric que
je vais dire y'en a pas
c'est juste moi qui me représente une
personne je disais donc moi je suis né
car est ce que je défini comme un
équilibre entre les sciences littérature
mais avec un manque d'habileté manuelle
conséquent et une sensibilité à l'art
proche de zéro quelle chance j'ai de
naître dans cette société où les
sciences sont mis à l'honneur
pas seulement en france mais bien dans
tous les pays du monde
trouvez moi un seul pays qui met l'art
plastique et les maths au même niveau
y'en a pas et pourtant on est tous
différents moi j'ai un avis qui est née
octogone et il n'a pas eu la même
scolarité que moi lui prêt manuel pas
justement il se trouvait pas dans ces
derniers lui qui a besoin de toucher
pour comprendre et imaginé pendant toute
sa scolarité à le donner comme moyen
pour s'exprimer
une feuille place des blanches c'est un
petit peu dommage faut bien comprendre
ou réalisés en fait que jusqu'au collège
il ya qu'un seul chemin des généralistes
il est unique comme j'ai dit et les
tracés par l'éducation nationale
dès qu'on dévie un petit peu de ce
chemin on est très souvent considéré
comme étant en échec scolaire
alors avant de parler du pelage revenons
un peu en arrière imaginez moi en fait
les grandes formes géométriques
peu importe que ça et chaque année on va
vous faire passer par des cadres et ça
passe plus ou moins bien
prenons la maternelle à la maternelle
c'est plus un octogone parce que vous
savez on fait plein de découvertes avec
le toucher on fait de la pâte à modeler
on fait aussi du dessin gribouillages je
n'étais pas très bon on découvre aussi
des chiffres on écoute beaucoup la
maîtresse enfin vous voyez l'idée
moi j'étais un carré j'ai pas trop aimé
on arrive en cp là pour moi le cbc plus
un cercle
on apprend à lire on apprend à écrire et
j'ai failli redoublent lcp par ce qui
est arrivé en avril ou quatre mois de la
fin des cours je disais avec beaucoup
discuté très très mal et j'écrivais
encore plus mal mais j'étais illisible
pour les autres mais surtout pour moi
c'est un problème
j'aimais pas écrire je trouve ça long
que ça fastidieux en fait quand des fois
je m'ennuyais comme ça je prenais ma
feuille je la mette à 90° et j'écrivais
sur les colonnes ont la preuve
et là vu écrire comme ça qu'elle a fait
mais maxime et à feuilles droite suit
les lignes et ça ira mieux
moi je lui avais dit mais attendez je
suis des lignes aussi et comme et sont
plus longs que je fais moins de retour à
la mine ville gagne du temps et je fini
par prendre ma feuille droit et en fait
quand j'ai écris stock je me suis dis
bah d'eau sinon je m'en souvienne c'est
la première fois qu'un professeur va
dire que je fais mal quelque chose parce
que je ne fais pas comme les autres
parce que je le fais pas comme on me l'a
appris à faire parce que vous êtes
d'accord j'écrivais sur des lignes mais
pas les bonnes car des centaines c'est
intéressant pour la suite
alors on arrive à prendre ses mains
valls terrain j'ai failli sauter la
jeunesse déjà en plus de pâte à modeler
gribouillages et on fait surtout
beaucoup plus de maths de logique
d'histoire géo de français j'ai quand
même fini par savoir lire et écrire
et donc j'ai failli sauter la grèce
pourquoi parce que pour moi ce cadre il
se rapprocher du carré donc j'avais
aucun problème on arrive ensuite au
collège alors le collège c'est dans la
continuité de la première un bon quart
est alors avec quelques côtes
extravagants vous savez la musique et
les arts plastiques et par contre
rassurez vous on retrouve toujours les
mêmes matières au top
les mad nous français la physique
histoire géo l'anglais r je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué
baverez pas mâché vous dans vos
bulletins de collège si vous avez encore
mais les trois matières qui sont marqués
tout le temps mais tout le temps à la
fin c'est le sport la musique et d'arts
plastiques vous en concluez ce que vous
voulez donc je disais donc que le
collège c'était dans la continuité de la
primaire mais à une différence près au
collège il ya quelque chose qui
s'appelle la puberté qui arrivent aussi
et on sait pas trop ce que c'est en tant
qu'enfant mais on sait qu'on a envie de
se sentir un peu plus grand plus
important dans envie de s'affirmer
on sait pas trop comment faire
malheureusement le moyen le plus facile
pour le faire c'est de rabaisser les
autres pour ça que moi je sais pas trop
éclatée au collège parce que j'étais un
peu le fayot j'étais un peu celui qui
arrive sans trop de difficulté et donc
je me suis pas trop épanoui je me
sentais pas trop à l'aise en fait danser
dans cet environnement qui me rejeter un
peu j'avais presque honte de réussir
quand je voyais mes amis donc
des triangles certes et encore il faut
imaginer la grand'rue géométriques qui
chaque année pour passer à l'année
supérieure mais quand le gars comme ça
il ya la faim ait donné un gros coup de
collier et ça passait il y avait la
partie qui bloquaient la qui se décroche
et qui restent derrière chaque fois
qu'il passait une année je voyais qu'il
y avait une partie d'eux-mêmes en fait
qui restaient derrière mais ce n'est pas
le plus de langues j'avais aussi
d'autres amis qui étaient elles trop
rigide qui allait pas cassé qui sortait
il se heurte à certaines qui sortaient
du cadre scolaire et après on les
appelait les sociétés en échec scolaire
et c'est un peu brutal je trouve
certains ont peut-être me dire là oui
mais quid du lycée et des études
supérieures je vous dirais que ça arrive
un peu trop tard quand on sort du
collège
on a 15 ans on est à l'école depuis nos
trois ans pendant douze ans on n'a pas
pu choisir une seule fois parce qu'on
voulait un peu et tu dis un peu triste
et et moi je me plains en quelque sorte
alors finalement je fais partie de la
bonne came kg et des élèves
celle qui a réussi avec les méthodes et
les programmes qu'on lui proposait mais
les autres les cercles qui sont perdus
en route les triant pas réussi à rentrer
dans le cadre malheureusement si on peut
vraiment être fiers d'avoir réussi dans
ce système scolaire qui vise un idéal
mais en omettant tous dans la main un
crayon comme seul moyen d'expression
dommage alors après je me suis intéressé
au métier maintenant pourquoi voulions
nous devenir telle ou telle personne ou
ce qu'on a envie et ce qu'on n'a pas
envie alors quand on est petit c'est ça
passe beaucoup par les super héros les
bébés les dessins animés est ce que
disent les adultes etc
et quand on grandit je pense
qu'inconsciemment il ya un autre
paramètre qui rentrent en jeu il y en a
plein il y en a un qui rentrent en jeu
c'est comment est perçu mon métier plus
tard
finalement quel statut je vais avoir ce
que le métier on va pas se mentir ça
prend si l'école prend tout notre temps
quand on est petit canton ayant les gars
on va on va bosser
donc du coup le métier prendre tout
notre temps mais c'est surtout une carte
d'identité classique et en maintenant la
question pourquoi il ya si peu
d'artistes peut-être si peu de musiciens
quand on prend toute la globalité de la
france pourquoi il ya de moins en moins
de jeunes qui veut le faire de la
en tissage qui sont volontaires pour
être maçon etc
parce qu'il faut beaucoup de courage
pour se lancer dans une voie qui est
très souvent très souvent peu reconnue à
sa juste valeur
c'est bien dommage je me suis aussi posé
la question inverse alors pourquoi les
sciences pourquoi les sciences ont-elles
le vent en poupe en ce moment
et voilà il faut revenir un peu en
arrière au 10e pole 19e siècle là où les
premiers systèmes on va dire scolaire de
masse qui s'adressent à toute une
population ont été inventés la france ne
fait pas exception avec jules ferry 1882
l'école devient publique laïque gratuite
et obligatoire de 5 6 ans jusque 13 14
ans alors c'est une entreprise très
louable à l'époque voilà ça servait les
intérêts de la france c'était pour
beaucoup pour alphabétiser en fait tous
et tous et ses paysans l'espace pérou
c'est une blague
et enfin vous voyez ce que je veux dire
et en plus c'était après un petit peu
pendant si la révolution industrielle
donc la société évolue à toute vitesse
je voulais absolument que les gens
puissent s'intégrer
j'étais bonne idée si on se plonge un
peu plus sur le programme maintenant il
y avait on trouvait beaucoup
d'arithmétique
on trouvait encore plus de français pour
une fois pour alphabétiser les gens et
entre eux aussi des travaux manuels
obligatoires on retrouvait la danse du
chant et la gymnastique
ma question c'est pourquoi en fait 136
ans après c'est encore la même chose
finalement j'ai même que c'est pire
parce que on a une société maintenant
qu'ils vouent un culte au progrès donc
on a encore plus de science pour caen -
travaux manuels
pourtant dieu sait qu'on préfère les tpe
et et emmène même si on regarde les les
dires des programmes scolaires
maintenant sont quasiment faits pour
faire les scientifiques pour créer des
scientifiques
pourquoi pas que ce sont des mauvaises
personnes
mon année j'ai fait ce que je veux dire
mais pourquoi eux parce que nous on va
je sais pas si enfin je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup d'italiens on va tous sortir
bin ça et on va tous pouvoir se
considérer comme faisant partie d'une
élite que la société reconnaît alors
qu'on n'a rien fait pour l'aisne n'a
fait une école
donc on va réussir presque parce que la
société ne veut alors sinon quand je dis
ça il ya déjà des fronts qui se plissent
comme ça en fait
on me dit souvent moi je dirais enfin
voila mon réussi aussi parce qu'on est
intelligent intelligent
qu'est ce que c'est être intelligent moi
j'ai beaucoup de mal à définir ce qu'est
l'intelligence avec un grand i moi je
pense que c'est une somme de savoirs
c'est une somme de savoirs faire aussi
mais du coup ce qu'on pouvait dire que
c'est une aisance d'esprit dextérité
d'esprit alors ça peut pas se traduire
manuellement oui c'est un peu gros en
tout cas dans ma tête c'est qu'on est
par contre ce que je sais c'est que
l'intelligence avec un grand oui n'est
que en toute petite partie représenter
une toute petite partie de
l'intelligence qui est mise en valeur de
la société
il faut qu'on accepte que l'intelligence
c'est un arbre à plusieurs branches et
donc il ya plusieurs chemins qui mènent
au tronc central
quelle intelligence on pense notre monde
avec nos cinq sens la vue et l'ouïe bien
sûr mais aussi par le toucher le goûter
les auteurs c'est donc normal que deux
personnes ne vont pas réagir pareil si
telle ou telle est sans cesse sollicité
chez eux
j'irai plus loin vous souvenez quand je
vais parler des domaines de prédilection
qui évolue on sait tous que notre
cerveau évolue en fait si on fait
travailler sur un exercice dont un sujet
on va devenir meilleur sur tel ou tel
exercice
mais par contre l'inversé est aussi vrai
si on laisse dépérir notre cerveau sur
un sujet aussi un domaine d'où vous
vient pas de faire actif et c'est pas
bon pour la créativité ce que je définis
que la captivité c'est vraiment la
capacité des humains à créer quelque
chose parce que c'est presque ce qui
fait la différence entre l'humain et la
caricature mais ce que je veux dire il
faut que nous soyons sollicité de
plusieurs manières sous plusieurs angles
pour être plus clair
dernière chose sur l'intelligence qui
permet vous travaille mieux sous
pression lever la main vite fait pour
voir il ya quand même pas mal de vendre
60 60 % et du pool et 70 peut-être et
les autres du coup en partiel là ça se
passe comment ça refait les années oui
est ce que je veux dire mon point c'est
que on réfléchit donc pas tous pareils
et surtout pas dans les mêmes conditions
je vous raconter une histoire c'est une
amie qui depuis qu'elle est toute petite
et très forte en dessin et dessine
beaucoup et surtout des vêtements ans
quand elle a grandi et s'est dit pas moi
je veux devenir styliste
jusque là c'est cohérent ses parents
bien nos plans de son rêve mais surtout
de son talent l'ont donc mis dans un
lycée général une filière es et ensuite
l'ont forcé à faire des années de fac
dans une fac de droit une fac de langues
puis une fac en gestion des entreprises
et des administrations
sans surprise elle a loupé à chaque fois
puisque le 4 mai correspondait pas alors
elle a pris ses créations et les envoyer
aux quatre coins de la france et elle a
été contactée
finalement pour une école d'art c'est ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui alors
l'histoire est vraie et là vous pensez
tous je pense aller mauvais parents
pourquoi penser comme ça votre avis
pourquoi voulait-il qu'elle rentre dans
une gaze que la société avait décidé
pour elle
peut-être qu'elle soit utile sais pas
trop et pourtant
sait-on vraiment de quoi allons-nous
avoir besoin dans 20 ans en trente ans
de quoi la société dans laquelle on vit
dedans aura de quoi la société at elle
besoin
si on continue à consumer autre planète
comme une vulgaire peau de chagrin
il aura besoin d'un miracle et ce
miracle ne se trouvera pas dans un
manuel scolaire dans des places dans les
professeurs les se trouvera dans un
cerveau créatif
encore une fois la créativité et
l'intelligence brut de l'humain sont les
valeurs ce sont des valeurs sûres non
pas devenir bête du jour au lendemain
mais c'est un don et c'est un don que
nous devons utiliser avec précaution car
il me vient une citation de john un seul
qu un biologie
américain qui disait que si les insectes
venait à disparaître
en l'espace de 50 ans toute forme de vie
si paraîtrait linverse si l'humain
venait de disparaître
en l'espace de 50 ans toutes formes de
vie prospérerait alors déjà su remettre
un peu au niveau des insectes par
constantin trucs mais je voulais c'est
avec cette dernière question comment
voulez vous qu'on fasse grandir une
nouvelle société qui va respecter ce que
les anciens n'ont pas su respecter mais
sans changer votre éducation
[Applaudissements]